well back here at minutemaid park the
astros getting set to take on the
seattle mariners
is that grinky to the mound making his
first start obviously here
in 2020. here is jp crawford
i went on the ground to altuve diving
stop gets up and throws what a play by
jose
altuve flashing the leather and an
outstanding
defensive play to get things going here
for the astros
secret three for eight with a homer rbi
live ball deep left center field towards
a garage door springer not going to get
it it's off the door
here comes kyle around third getting the
wave on correa's throw
not in time it's cut off by gorielle and
kyle seeger staying hot
rbi double one-nothing mariners well you
take a look at the swing going the other
way
drives this off what looks like a garage
door out there
with two outs louis able to score easily
he's off as soon as he makes contact but
kyle off to a great start couple of
doubles now in a home run
and the count is one and two on white
here's the pitch on the way
swinging a shot into left field down the
line and that's going to be a base hit
here comes seeger ronnie third heading
home
up with the ball is bradley the throw to
second is cut off by correa
evan white with a base hit and a run bad
and then picks up his first
major league rbi with a shot to left
field and the mariners have a two
nothing lead
over the astros way to go kid white with
a solid single to left field
he got a slider out over the plate
seeger scores
so two runs are in here at the top of
the first inning
you say kaguchi 29 year old from
oreoka japan making the start today for
the seattle mariners
michael bradley had a three-run home run
in the opener of this series
kikuchi looks in from the stretch checks
the runner and the 2-2 pitch it is
strike three called on the inside corner
a little cut fastball right there
and brantley is caught looking strikeout
number one on the season for you
kikuchi and the astros have two outs
here in the bottom of the first
and that'll bring up third baseman alex
bregman here's one hit
could get into the gap running try and
the catch is not
made ball is down altuve comes around
third base
he'll head for home here's the throw
he's safe throw to third
and bregman is out at third base but an
rbi double and the astros are
on the board they cut the deficit in
half as seattle leads it 2-1
so joe biagini on the mound for the
astros on and relief
three in the third innings for grinke
giving up a couple of runs and lopes on
at second base still belongs to
grinke the pitch alex's swing and a fly
ball deep to right field
and this one is going to be on the
warning track all the way to the wall
lopes heading for third the throw into
second base
and tim heading home and he will score
malik smith and at second base with a
double the right field and it's now the
mariners three and the astros one to the
top of the order here's shed long junior
astros trailing three to one been out
hit
five to two the stretch and the pitch
fastball swinging a line drive the other
way down the left field line it's going
to be a fair ball in toward the corner
smith the third he's ronnie third
heading home he will score the marion
has put up another run here in the
fourth and in its second base goes shed
long
with an rbi double the mariners now lead
the astros
four to one here in the top of the
fourth inning three doubles for the
mariners here
in the fourth and shed picks up his
first rbi of the season
mariners just trading places in this
inning he's in a whole bunch of hot
water here in the bottom of the fourth
inning with altuve and at third brantley
on its second bregman on it first
and now he's got to take a look at first
baseman julie guriel who had a home run
yesterday
2-2 pitch again hit into left field
that's down for a hit
altuve will score as the astros play
station to station and the bases now
continue to be loaded with nobody out
with a run and it's four to two
good piece of hitting by euless 3-0
pitch with the bases loaded in two outs
walked him on four pitches and it's four
to three an rbi
walked by josh reddick the astros closed
within a run
did such a good job in getting correa
and jones
and then all of a sudden it turned into
a yard sale up down
in out and up for the final ball leading
to another run for the houston astros
and it gets right-handed hitting
martine maldonado up there who's been
swinging the bat well in the first
couple of games
maldonado on the ground that's a fair
ball down the line
bregman scores here comes julie he'll
score
and another big hit by martine maldonado
you talk about a guy that's been
money through the first three games of
this season and the astros take the lead
five to four
that is a great swing he has been
getting the head out in the first two
now three games
and he knows kikuchi is going to come
attacking with that fastball that's why
he's so far out in front of that
so kikuchi's day is done and the astros
are
on top five to four she had one for four
with an rbi
second hit of this early going
opportunity and knocking here for the
mariners in the eighth down a run
in hard base hit right field
there comes lopes there's the throw not
in time todd ball game shed long with a
game
single knotted up at 5-5
second rbi today for shed a second hit
today lopes scores and the ball game is
tied at 5-5
shedlong jr with a hard ground ball
through the right side of the infield
lopes coming in from second down to
second goes nola
along with his second run bad at end of
the afternoon it's now the mariners five
and the astros five
so now the mariners have two on in score
position give long a steal
all tied at 5-5 and the count evens up
on lewis
go ahead run at second and base hit
right field
redick with the big arm nola scores
right behind him and [ __ ] look he's in
there safely
a great slide three runs are in for the
mariners here in the top of the eighth
inning they lead it
seven to five over the astros taylor
williams a new pitcher trying to close
it out but for his first career save
so brantley with two outs bradley hits
this one
to right field and that is down for a
ground rule double so that will score
tucker and brantley
will go into second base as it bounces
over the right field fence
and the astros get a run here in the
ninth to cut the lead to one
it's all come down to this three and two
mariners up a run
time run at second three two pits to
bregman swinging
as he struck him out and the mariners
win at 7-6
taylor williams this first big league
saved the mariners
in the 15-game losing streak to the
astros
12 games down in houston they needed it
congratulations
fellas